my god good how you doing I'm good
how much fun did you have with these
guys man these guys are the best and
their family they take care of us it is
right there look at our standard I might
have take a family fortune you want to
be on every piano from here to tell the
world you were weird but
we got to break this up I love all y'all
I love all y'all but we gotta break this
up love you can go see Jumanji the next
level my joints feel like wow I didn't
have tequila that's the only reason I
don't give me that here's the rim
you notice my look lit up and take it
yes you can take mine we're gonna
celebrate your hand print and footprints
going in tomorrow how big is that how
big is that that is you know what can
see I can't even be a jerk because you
came and you hit me with a nice gesture
off the bed that's huge man that's very
huge I'm excited I'm very excited man
it's a big deal now I know DJ you've
done this already I have is your remind
him remind everybody help I've already
done it call him a man it's happening
it's happening these eggs hand and foot
prints ceremony baby yeah I did it what
do you want big deal no I'm so happy and
so proud of him I am I have the
privilege of speaking on his behalf
tomorrow and I can't wait I did have the
honor of having it done and by the way
not to mess with them but I know how
cool it is
yeah and I'm so happy that he's
experiencing it this is the great
Christmas it's a great holiday you know
this guy's had I mean what a year and
here we are
I'm so happy to celebrate my guy Kevin
have you become an influencer
fashion-wise on DJ you know what I wish
well cuz they know I've always been a
stylist because they know guy everybody
knows this
well you know what I will say this so
you gotta take your head off to him big
fellas turned it on over the past couple
years man it's really turning on not
that he didn't have it on before but he
turned it on not loving that's good
tonight
urban naughty tell me about this DJ
because that's a ok thank you very much
custom-made Dolce Louboutin not Louis
Vuitton happy to wear these threads but
look at my boy well I'm gonna tell you
something you've worn that I've seen
that before right you rock that I
remember this no because I'm gonna give
him suits about the design designer with
McQueen this is a pattern that they're
known for Thank You Cal cleaned it up
for you man oh boy if this was at 7 Pete
this would have been a bad day how many
times were wear that you dirty actor
it's new no but I mean you like that
designer with the whole I love McQueen
and I love it when they do their floral
pins for sure I mean but I'm very weird
don't see what I'm fast you know to that
I don't have to tell you will you miss
this tour now that it's over that's the
first time anyone has asked to set I
will miss it I have had I've had the
greatest time I have a truly the most
joyful time with Kevin and the cast
traveling and it helps it we made a
great movie you know and my guy here
just you know the times we've had the
interviews they've been up then ever
epic everything's gonna
the cast in general the project you know
at the end of the day you're promoting
something that you're proud of
that's you're happy about and we both
understand how fortunate we are to be in
this particular franchise to be able to
discuss that it's this has been one for
the record book all right we're doing a
thing called eat eat up and your
co-hosts have been asking questions your
co-stars have been asking questions so
now you have to answer a question and
ask a question okay the last question of
one of your co-stars left was who was
your first real celebrity crush that you
had to spend a little private time with
yuniko heart Mego heart my wife my wife
didn't hear me it's my wife did they
hear that does everybody hear that I got
okay well for real men Lauren Johnson my
wife
[Music]